Patty Galloway runs one of the most
successful in-demand businesses on
YouTube that's not on YouTube throughout
the last several years he's cracked the
code of the YouTube algorithm and
manages some of the largest channels on
the platform with a never-ending wait
list from the opposite side of the world
today we're going to break down his
million dollar per year business the
secrets of building a YouTube Empire and
how you can get started as soon as you
see I was gonna say that just said it
hey just hit the Subscribe button and
we'll start
but first we have to thank today's
sponsor Kudos because you guys know
exactly how much I've talked about
credit cards and saving money in the
past but even for someone as cheap as
gray Frugal but even for someone as
Frugal as Graham trying to fully
maximize your credit cards points and
rewards ends up being way too
complicated and time consuming and that
is where Kudos comes in Kudos is a
browser extension that shows you the
best credit cards to use for online
checkout they support over 3 000
different cards and all you have to do
is enter which cards you use and they'll
recommend the best ones for any online
purchase you make the average Kudos
customer saves over 750 a year which is
insane they even look for some of the
Hidden rewards like travel insurance and
purchase protection that so many people
forget about my favorite part of Kudos
is the card Explorer tool which shows
you which cards you should apply for
based on the ones you already have they
also have an autofill feature that not
only saves you money but also your time
Kudos is currently us only in offering
our listeners a 10 Amazon gift card when
you use code iced coffee the underscore
BF what was GF taken yes it was all you
got to do is make your first autofill
purchase before December 5th and a 10
Amazon gift card will be delivered
directly to the email address you signed
up with again you could use the link
Down Below in the description and sign
up with the code iced coffee underscore
BF so they know we sent you
there we go welcome to the iced coffee
hour Patty we are elated to have you
yeah you got to do your intro Patty
welcome to the ice coffee hour this is
going to be a YouTube Master Class wow
in person that's fantastic yeah Patty we
are excited to have you on I've been a
fan of your channel for a very long time
you're a student of the YouTube
algorithm you know all these hacks where
these people can basically growth hack
their YouTube channels into blowing up
and consistently making high performing
videos and turning those into
multi-million dollar businesses you
consult some of the biggest creators out
there on their YouTube channels and make
some amazing content yourself thank you
for coming on thank you I mean it's it's
been a long time coming we talked about
this a long time ago so it's it's great
to be here I listened to this podcast
myself really so it is pretty surreal
being here I'm looking forward to diving
into everything and going through it all
yeah I had no idea by the way that you
ran an entire agency in a business
around helping other creators grow their
channels and them making more money too
and I had no idea that was making that
much money you had said something like
fifty thousand dollars a month yeah I
mean that might be a bad month right now
it's a bad month we're trying we're
aiming for a 100K a month is where I
want to be and I think I think it is
possible like we've got close to that a
few times pretty much touching you know
in the 90s and so yeah I mean it's funny
because I I was making the videos first
just because I genuinely loved making
the videos it wasn't because I saw like
a business opportunity because I've been
doing YouTube since 2006 in some form or
another and essentially I just kept
having people reach out to me saying Hey
do you do Consulting like no do you do
Consulting no you do Consulting we'll
pay you this much
no do your consultant will pay this much
and give you this and do that I'm like
okay actually let's give this a try I
tried it a few times did it with a few
different channels first one the first
um channels I work with with like 3x
views from like 20 million views a month
to 60 million views a month and I was
like this could be a business 260 no 20
million
per month wow wow so yeah I'm curious
when when you're looking at 20 million
views a month I would see that and be
like oh that's pretty good let's just
let's let's keep that how could we
sustain that how do you take that from
20 to 60 and wouldn't they just think
I'm getting 20 million views a month
this is pretty good why do I need your
help I think it comes down to the person
like some people are just perfectly okay
with maintaining but it does depend on
the niche because let's say Finance like
you're like top of the finance game I
think that goes without saying and like
the the actual ceiling of where you can
be like I would always say we could
always do more we could always maybe
double what we're doing when you look at
something like Minecraft which is the
channel I was talking about there it was
a Minecraft Channel I work with like
Minecraft is the biggest game in the
world because Minecraft channels that
get 20 30 million views of video so when
I look at a niche like that I see the
ceiling and say
like why not shoot for 60 million why
not shoot for 100 million views a month
so I think it depends on the niche like
some people they have a hard ceiling and
they just kind of float below that
ceiling some people like it's Limitless
can you tell us when you initially
looked at that channel what were some of
the biggest faults that you recognized
in that channel and things that they can
improve on to go from 20 million to 60
million views a month I think in in that
case it was very early in my journey to
be fair and it was it was like my first
foray into Consulting and into doing
this as a business so I looked at a
channel like that and I just saw huh
we're not really learning enough from
data we're not really thinking enough
about ideas we're not doubling down on
the ideas that are working and like I
don't want to take all the credit the
team that was working on that was was
phenomenal and we managed to just all do
this together to get to the point where
it got to 60 million views a month but
more more recently when I look at a
channel because of the experience I have
now because that was quite a few years
ago I can go in straight away and almost
like Plug and Play It's like this
channel has untapped potential
they should be doing more with the
thumbnails they should be spending more
time on their intros they are making
obvious mistakes in the retention and I
look at that and say I have this
experience I have the team I can go in
and we can scatter to the moon and how
much do they pay you for that service it
kind of depends like my hourly rate
would sort of flow between 500 an hour
to about a thousand an hour depending on
the situation then as well like we can
get into kind of like Revenue share
agreements with certain channels which
could become more lucrative and
sometimes as well like performance
bonuses so like maybe they pay me 500 an
hour but then if we hit a certain view
threshold I would get an extra bonus or
something like that so sure it can be
quite lucrative yes so let's talk about
because you you seem to be very well
versed kind of an expert on everything
YouTube how did you get to this point
tell us your story where you started
from how did you learn all and
experience all this stuff for yourself
and then teach it to other people I mean
I think I think a lot of it comes from
growing up in Ireland so I'm Irish of
course as you can tell from the accent
and yeah like in Ireland I lived like 20
30 minutes away from all my friends I
lived in rural Ireland in the in the
countryside and during the Summers you
know we have these I think he's the same
here like sort of three month break
summer break I didn't have anything to
do so I was like 10 11 12. I got a
camera for Christmas one year like a lot
of YouTubers say started filming videos
and I just loved it like I loved making
videos I just loved the pursuit of just
shooting something even if it was really
just like a prank on my brother just
something random and then I saw YouTube
and I was like like this is a place I
can actually share that because I wanted
to be a filmmaker and I saw YouTube and
I was like you know if I want to put
something on TV there's all these hoops
you have to jump through with YouTube
it's just like press upload bang so I
started uploading videos there there and
I think I think it really helped me
because I never thought never saw it as
like an opportunity to make money or an
opportunity to to build a business I
just saw it as like this is really cool
I want to do this so I started posting
videos just of myself my brother in like
2007 2008. so we're talking like old
school YouTube like there's no algorithm
it's all just the you know subscription
feeds and like top rated video of the
week and all that sort of stuff even
back then like I loved it I realized
that the first love of mine was the
actual content creation and the second
of is the analytics behind it like why
something goes viral and I have
notebooks at home from when I'm 12 13
years old where I would like track the
views on successful videos because
something like socialblade didn't exist
back then so like the new Linkin Park
song will come out and I'd be just
tracking the numbers day by day and
trying to figure out okay where where is
this video gonna end up how many views
is it going to get and that was again
when I was 12 13. and then since then I
mean all my life I've had a YouTube
channel in some form or another when I
was younger I had a lot of music
channels the most successful one of
which got about 56 million views use
about 120 000 subscribers so that was
enough to actually start making a living
with YouTube and I was like I can do
this for a living which is like it was
Irish hip-hop
no no no no no no no no no don't do not
get me to rap no definitely
at some point
if you're listening he's gonna rap at
the end and stay tuned at some point
retention yeah actually we got it we
gotta say it's at some point in the
video that way you have to watch all the
way through we're not going to announce
it yeah oh my God I'm already nervous no
but yeah like it was a mini Irish
hip-hop and it's funny whenever I say
that people I was like Irish hip-hop
like what are you talking about like
leprechauns and bars you know and
whiskey but uh yeah there's actually
really there's a really cool hip-hop
scene in Ireland so I was filming videos
and posting it on this channel I like
I've got a video on there with 35 minute
views on this channel and what are the
the demographics of the viewers on the
demographics Irish it's it's actually
it's funny it's mainly British it's
about 70 British and about 20 Irish and
then the rest of the world like I go
into an analytics sometimes and I see
views from like Korea like Australia and
it's it's pretty crazy but I stopped
that channel a long time after the air
the PewDiePie thing happened and AD
raids got crushed I just completely like
I was making a bit of money doing it
like not enough to like go crazy but
enough to like make a living as a 17 18
19 year old but then the PewDiePie
apocalypse happened in 2017 and I went
from making a few thousand a month to
like 100 a month and that's when I
actually came up with the the current
Channel that's interesting and then at
what point did you realize you could
begin turning this into a business
because at that point where did you want
to go to school
yeah it's funny so I was actually I was
actually saying this to someone earlier
it's like when when I was graduating
high school so I was like 18 19. I had a
channel that had at the time 80 000
subscribers this hip-hop Channel and it
was making me a little bit of money and
I was learning a lot and if you thought
of a kid today that has that is 18 and
has a channel that's making actual
physical money and he's growing
subscribers you'd say take a shot do it
but that never even crossed my mind back
then like I thought no this is like this
is not an opportunity so I went to
college I just didn't think it would be
something that would work and I think
some of that is probably
being Irish and being from Ireland it's
a great country but it's very much like
you do this you know like one thing I
love about America even since just being
here for the last few days is everyone
is so like encouraging and Ireland I
love it but just in general people like
you know no who do you think about you
know you know you're the Irish guy from
you know Carlow in Ireland which is
where I'm from you know you just stick
to your lane you do this you become a
mechanic you go to college you become an
engineer or something you know so it's a
bit different like it just never crossed
my mind and then I realized after doing
a bit of college and after working at
nine to five for a while I was like I
was making as much money doing YouTube
than I am doing a nine to five that I do
not like what was your nine to five it
was in a marketing agency so I was doing
like Facebook ads we were also running
conferences as well like business
conferences and events and it was like
it was okay but like I say nine to five
it was nine to nine like I was working
all the time and it was like 12 an hour
I was like I was making as much money if
not more money on YouTube and I was like
why not just double down and actually
see the opportunity there it's funny
because that's only what four or five
years ago
but even four or five years ago YouTube
wasn't the place it is now like it was
it was almost more of a stigma like you
like everyone thought this was just
gonna last a year two years like people
didn't think they could build
sustainable careers I think that's
really changed over the last like five
years yeah I don't know I remember I
started late 2016. I thought it was too
late
everyone's already done it everything's
already saturated who would care it's
like but looking back I'm like oh wow no
little did I know there's still so much
opportunity and so much would happen
makes me think now every time someone
says oh no it's so saturated now what
does that mean five years from now would
you look back at that and think oh man
it would would have been easy back then
there's all these new segments that just
don't exist yet that's what I think is
very cool
yeah I mean that's that's a good point I
think yeah that might be the the Irish
culture in me just not not seeing the
opportunity as much as as an American
might yeah but first today's video is
sponsored by epidemic sound the best for
creators to soundtrack their content
yeah seriously we've been using epidemic
sound now for years and they've been one
of the best platforms to soundtrack all
of our videos without getting
demonetized trust me when I say that
dealing with takedowns and copyright
claims is one of the most frustrating
Parts about being a Creator and having
access to high quality copyright free
music is seriously one of the most
essential tools for Content creation all
tracks are professionally produced by a
diverse collection of artists and are
exclusive to epidemic sound that means
you're not going to find them anywhere
else they offer both a personal and
Commercial plan with a personal plan
ideal for creators that are on YouTube
twitch Instagram Facebook whatever
basically all of them all of them once
again guys we've been using epidemic
sound for like two years now if you go
back to the second ever video posted on
this family you can see in the intro we
use an epidemic Sound song those are
good times man those are good times so
use that link Down Below in the
description to get a 30-day free trial
to access epidemic sounds diverse music
catalog again the link is down below in
the description to get started today and
with that said let's get back to the
podcast so you decided to quit your job
and you went all in on this music
channel at the time no so at the time
like the the music channel in in 2017 it
kind of wrapped up because of the
adpocalypse because it just it just
wasn't sustainable pun intended wrapped
up yeah yeah yeah it actually wasn't but
I'll take it I definitely meant that you
did that on purpose but yeah like I'd
wrap that up and I was like you know I
know a lot about YouTube that wasn't the
only Channel I was running like we would
be here all day if I talked through
every channel I think I counted it one
day and it's like 40 channels 40
channels I would say to that that's too
many channels it's way too many but if
you're a kid who's interested in things
like and loves YouTube like let's just
say I get into like parkour which I
didn't but let's just say I did Channel
you know I got into like calisthenics
like body weight exercises Channel I got
into like EDM music channel I got into
rap Channel like whatever I was doing I
was creating a channel around it so you
can imagine as like you know when you're
12 13 14 you just have a different hobby
every week so every week I'd start a new
channel and most of it I mean like I
would say 98 of them never got past the
thousand subscribers but a couple of
them did and then I just I was like damn
I know a lot about YouTube so 2017
happened the adpocalypse happened I was
like I know a lot about YouTube and
YouTube advice content in my opinion at
the time was good but it was kind of
boring I thought like I thought I could
provide something different so I was
like I just remember saying to myself so
vividly you know
what could I do that's more original and
how like is it possible to get a YouTube
advice video that gets a million views
and it kind of It kind of sprung from
there just that thought of like what if
it's not just top five tips to grow a
YouTube channel what if you like made a
story out of a YouTuber's journey and uh
yeah I guess the rest what was the first
video you made on that was that Mr Beast
no the first video I made was the Peter
McKinnon breakdown and a fun story about
this so the channel I made it on which
is obviously my channel now that had a
different name and I essentially used it
as almost like a bit of a like a a
Content Farm Channel a guy made like top
five moments and I had like 20 000
subscribers and maybe like 10 million
views because a conversion with
subscribers is very low for that type of
content so I was doing that and it was
like you know a bit of fun I was making
a little bit of cash doing that
um but then I had this thought like I
said of the you know the YouTube advice
video that could get a million views
like what does that actually look like
and essentially a few months prior to
that I had studied Peter McKinnon's
success like studied his journey and I
was like how did this happen because he
kind of came out of nowhere like he was
like especially back then it was like
him and Casey neistat were like you know
top of my mind so I had almost like
wrote an essay for myself
just to like learn from his journey and
his success I was like damn this guy's
really interesting let me write down
like a little bit of like a do some
notes and write like a story for myself
to read back then I looked at it and I
said you know this could be a video and
this could be exactly what I was
thinking about like a YouTube advice
video that could hit a million viewers
and I uploaded uploaded it to that
channel 60 views in the first day
and on that channel I was usually
averaging a few thousand views in the
first day about 60 views and I just
looked at it and I said this isn't going
to work you know I'm going to go back to
the ninth five like this this doesn't
work right and the funny story about it
is I just I remember like shutting it
and like signing into a different
YouTube account because I had so many
different YouTube accounts and just
signing out going about my day and then
I was in Dublin the capital of Ireland
um a few weeks later and a guy I know
came up to me and he was like Patty I
really like that video you posted about
Peter McKinnon I was like that's funny
that's really Nisha who'd find that like
you know what must have like 100 views
by now log back into my studio or my
desktop because I didn't even have it on
a mobile I don't even know if YouTube
mobile was even there YouTube Studio was
even there
I open up the YouTube Studio 300 000
views and I was like damn people want
this type of content and that's kind of
how the channel grew from there how much
you make from that video do you remember
the orphans were pretty decent actually
YouTube advice content I think I think
like that video alone like right now
it's got 1.1 million so I remember the
first check that came in for that first
month was like 2K something like that
like 2 000. I think in the first month
they did like 500 000 views so that was
the first check I instantly bought a
laptop and then uh that's kind of how it
snowballed when you quit your job I
finished up my job the following summer
that's when I kind of wrapped everything
up which was I think 2018 yeah and at
that point in time actually this channel
like my current Channel it was in a bit
of a lull I'd made a few videos in in
the the meantime while I was still
working the job some of them had done
well like I made a video on Casey
neistat got like 600 000 views but I
made a video on Alpha M and unboxed
therapy and they both kind of
underperformed for where I was aiming
for and then I like I finished up the
job and I was feeling like honestly like
a bit depressed I was like you know
what's the next what's the next step for
me like what do I do next because I'm
the sort of person that always has to be
working towards something big like I
realized in the nine to five like if
someone said you worked this nine to
five you make this much money and then
you go up and you do another few years
and you do this like it just doesn't
excite me itself like I want rapid I
want to do things and move things
forward so I was kind of in this period
where I was like yeah I don't know like
should I just quit the channel should
try to do something else I went down
this Rabbit Hole of like trying to start
other businesses and thinking like oh
I'm gonna get into Drop Shipping I'm
gonna get into this and that I was
trying all these like silly things and
wasting my time and I was like let me
just give this a really good go with the
Paddy Galloway channel that people know
from today day and I went back started
making a few videos the results were
slow I made one of Matt diavela they're
like 40 000. they wanted Peter McKinnon
did 80 000 and I was like oh this is
something I made a video on PewDiePie
and it absolutely flopped it did it did
terrible first week it did like 3000
views and you know I was I was
accustomed to like 600 000 then a
million and I was like God like I was
thinking I might actually quit like I
might actually just stop YouTube
before I stopped YouTube I said I'll
make one more video and that video was
the video of Mr Beast so I was like this
this Mr Beast kid like this is 2019 so
obviously it was big but he wasn't like
big big I was like this guy's amazing
like he's getting like he's got 20
million subscribers he's getting like 20
million views of video let me make a
breakdown video on him so I just said
this is my last chance Saloon and I
don't want to like make it too dramatic
but like that was literally what I was
saying I remember looking at the
computer screen and saying as I was
writing the script this could be the
last YouTube video I make made that
video
press upload first day pretty good I
don't even remember if we had rankings
back then so not so long and I thought
maybe I can't remember but I uploaded
the video I was like okay posted checked
it I was like oh performing quite well
like I think it had like a few thousand
views in the first few days and my
videos would always start slow anyway
started picking up and I saw oh 20 000
views this is interesting and it was it
was right around Christmas of 2019
and then I woke up one morning and I had
like 35 000 views and it jumped up
overnight and the interesting thing is
Nate O'Brien who I know you guys are
very good friends with this is his hotel
room shout out NATO shout out Nate
he commented on the video and this is
the first time he'd interacted with my
channel he commented on the video saying
dude this is going to get a million
views I remember him saying like I saw
the comments like I should go back and
find it like if anyone wants to look it
up it's probably still on that video and
I saw that I was like yeah a million
views like that'd be crazy like I was
just thinking I'd love this to get a
hundred thousand
and then the day after that it got 500
000 views in one day Mega viral next day
after that it got 600 000 views and that
was Christmas Eve and Christmas Day it
did 650 000 views and my YouTube Studio
was just bananas like I was looking at
it and I was like two million views in
my real time you know and the video
before on PewDiePie it's done well now
because over time it's it's ranked in
Search and done well but again that was
2 000 views in the in the first like two
weeks this video had three million views
in the first two weeks and I was like
okay this is something that I could
really really do and stick to so that
was like the second quitting point so I
was thinking of quitting did that I
thought you know underneath I nearly was
like you know the YouTube algorithm has
just blessed me they knew I was going to
quit and they were like let's give them
another shot but I think it was just a
well-timed video at the at the right
time and the numbers speak for
themselves it's interesting because
Darman had a very similar story he said
he was about to quit and told his now
wife this is the last video I'm posting
and they're done posted the video and
the next day got like a million views on
Facebook and that's what gave him the
encouragement to keep going so it's
amazing how many times you make that
last video and it's not the last one but
you got to mentally go in thinking this
is the last one and then it'll blow up
it's also very cool when you post a
video and people say this is going to
get a million views here before a
million views this video is about to
blow up because usually they're right if
if I usually get about two dozen of
those comments like here before a
million views this is gonna get it
always does and I think the viewers know
just like if the how the video is going
to perform in the first 20 minutes it's
pretty remarkable they found something
fresh yes you know like maybe those
viewers had watched the YouTube voice
videos and they're like oh there's some
good advice here but kind of boring but
then
not to give myself too much credit there
wasn't really anyone else doing those
breakdown videos you know there's a lot
more now but at the time I was like the
first person to do these breakdown
videos so seeing something completely
new and fresh on your feed that you know
people were just like damn this is
interesting so I think I think that
isn't good now what I find interesting
too I just thought of this is that you
make these very good come up videos like
the the you know the rise of a certain
Creator whereas other people like
sunnyv2 talk about now the downfall of
the greatest so you like the ride up and
he's the the ride down have you found
that maybe more you know the negative
videos tend to do better because I'm
watching a lot of sunnyv2 oh my gosh his
views his uh James Corden video yeah
over a million views now in nine hours
yeah how is that on our trending and
that's it just seems like it's organic
and in all of his subscribers click it
because they just want to know what's
the downfall I I am so
but part of me I watch those videos
thinking what could I avoid because if
they're all making these mistakes how
can I not make those mistakes you know
what can I not do yeah so it's
interesting because I remember when he
first started posting videos and I saw
him when he had like 10 000 subscribers
and I thought he was copying me a little
bit not not to take a shot like I kind
of thought he was doing like the rise of
Mark Rover and I was like you know I was
like oh he's kind of I'm taking a bit of
inspiration for me but like when he when
he switched that complete like downfall
yeah like I mean just look at the view
counts like I kind of I don't do badly
at all I averaged like 900 000 per video
when you just combine my last 30 videos
but like this guy gets like a guaranteed
million views of video he's got like
four minute views five minute views six
minute views yeah I think this just is
more of a desire for it and a lot of
people like I've had people tell me like
what like I had people tell me before he
even came along why don't you do the
downfall on people yes and not to like
make myself sound like holier than that
or whatever because I think it's just
content at the end of the day but like
at this conference like I'm walking into
people the way I see this is YouTube is
like super stressful and again I think
Sony V2 is a genius like I think he's
brilliant like he's honestly and I've
actually had a few messages what I mean
he seems like a really nice guy yeah so
like absolutely no shade at all that's
that's to me like imagine I just imagine
like let's just say padigato it fell off
like not that I'm at this huge level but
let's just say I fell off yeah like I
would just I would feel so bad about
that I'd be like really like shamed I
feel like horrible about that I'd like
to think I would find a way out of it
and figure out how to like blow up again
but if that was the case and then I'm
just like you know in a bad mood and
then I just see on my news page page
like the downfall of Paddy Gallery but
you know what I have to say he does them
in such a way where it's not him coming
up with these opinions he's just
reporting yeah so like he did one he did
one on Andrew Hales and Andrew watched
the video and I watched Andrew's
reaction of it it was so good and Andrew
was like yeah I think it's a pretty
balanced video he's right that's Andrew
you can't base everybody else off of
Andrew he takes things very lightly I
think there's yeah like you have to if
you're reporting something you have to
kind of understand that you're also
publicizing certain and things and you
usually don't accurately portray both
sides you sensationalize it because
that's what gets the views yeah it's
some of that but usually in his videos
you can point to something and some of
these videos like all right yeah I agree
with that that makes sense but I see I
see your point though like for example
like there was a like I feel like I'm
quite like immune so that's like I don't
care what people say but maybe it's
because like I'm not on camera so like
they're not they're not personal attacks
you know so maybe if I actually felt
what that was like I'd be different but
like in January and February and March I
had a few videos underperformed on my
channel I had a video that the first
Ryan train video hit like I think it's
like 130k the Matthew beam one like
underperformed as well and I remember
just being so like disappointed with
that because there's nothing worse than
like a 10 out of 10 like it just hurts
especially as the end of 2021 I had like
3.5 million on a Beluga video 3.9
million on a Mr B squared game video so
I was like on this Ultimate Buzz then I
get like 130k and I get 90k and I
remember just feeling terrible and then
I I tweet something and like someone
replies the Tweet just saying like dude
you fell off look at your views that's
like a tenth of what you got last year
like what is going on like is the
content like if you've done something
wrong and like I know I should look at
that and reflect and say yeah I am doing
something wrong like there was a reason
those didn't perform there were body
times they were not the best videos I
did mistakes in those videos
but like it kind of hurt I was like damn
like you know it's kind of bad to
actually fail publicly and then someone
to say like you're doing you're doing
wrong and I just remember when I made
that Ryan train penny series video in
June and that one hit a million views
before pressing that that video before
pressing privilege I was so terrified
that sounds strange to someone whose
income is not tied to his channel and
he's been on YouTube for so long to be
so terrified of pressing published but I
was like if this video flops as well
like I'm done like that's how I thought
yeah and like I don't know but doesn't
it in a way affect you professionally
because if your clients see you like
even if you have results with your
clients but if they see you not having
videos that perform does that cast doubt
in their mind even though it doesn't
reflect on them I think that yeah I
think there is a point there like I do
think that helps me because like there's
quite a lot of people that talk about
YouTube there's not many people talk
about YouTube and actually get a million
views on videos so I do I do think
that's a factor yes I think the one
thing to consider though is like
naturally YouTube advice content
shouldn't have the audience that mine
does in my opinion like if you look at
any other channel buyer Collins Amir
have done a phenomenal job like most of
them struggle to crack 100K so when I
get a video that hits 140k it's like
compared to everything else it's a
massive underperformer but when you
consider the audience I'm trying to
actually Target at the end at the end of
the day not trying to downplay it but I
feel like
you know let's just say if someone was
getting 50 000 views of video on YouTube
advice I think they were a good YouTuber
you know because it's difficult there's
lots of people doing it it's competitive
but I do definitely think it does help
with reputation with clients being able
to say look I can make a good video
um and even like a funny thing like I
saw this post screenshots on Twitter of
like analytics and and results I get for
myself and other people one time I
posted a screenshot of a video with like
1.9 million views or whatever on that
that Mark I got this DM from someone who
like you know you're just photoshopping
this you know I want to see some proof
for this performance and I just linked
him the video and it was on my channel
and I was like dude like just look up my
channel it's right there you know so it
definitely helps in that regard to be
like I know what I'm talking about got
it how many clients do you have now
full-time clients yeah I have I believe
it's five between five and seven it kind
of varies with some people that dip in
dip out can you say who your clients are
I can say that the YouTube channels I
can't say the corporations I work with
sure
um I work with Noah Kagan he's he's like
no I work with like you know he he was a
perfect example of selecting someone who
I thought could blow up because he's got
like a crazy track record crazy
reputation he's got resources and he's
actually really passionate about YouTube
like he wants to grow on YouTube
assistant he's consistent that's what I
like the most about him is that very few
people in at his League have the
consistency to post no matter what yeah
because he he had gone through three
years two maybe two years of just the
same results but he still kept posting
and he still kept trying to do YouTube
yeah and anyway I came in I talked to
his producer we talked about like a
strategy we could apply in the channel
funny funny story is like I've been
working with Noah for like
nearly a year and then this this
conference that Summit is like the first
time I've actually really had a
conversation with him because like he's
got everything so scaled like every like
he's just kind of like in front of the
camera but everything around him is like
systemized so anyway like
I looked at the channel and they were
doing like 20 to 50 000 views of video
some sometimes outliers but three times
a week in my opinion the content was
good but it was like sitting at the desk
it wasn't too creative and like I think
there was a bit of a ceiling to it so
when I came in and the the guys uh the
producer and and Noah himself the
producer Jeremy they agreed that like we
need to be more selective we need to go
for bigger Swings with the content and
like you know so we started applying
that we started actually posting less
but we went for bigger swings like Noah
was actually out and about asking
millionaires how to make a million and
they came up with that idea they came up
with the idea but I I came up with the
thumbnail Concepts and it might like I'm
not trying to take credit for but I
think that thumbnail concept is
brilliant I just love that paused
reaction of oh him at the door with the
door kind of open yeah yeah I like that
yeah so like that video that was the
first video we did together the first
time that I worked on with them that
video is like 3.5 million now and like
ever since then like I think on average
I worked it out for my vid summer
presentation like on average we're doing
about 500 000 views of video now whereas
before it was 50 000 and that's just by
being more selective and going for like
bigger swings and I I thought that was
possible the minute I saw Noah and talk
to him and talk to Jeremy on his team I
was like
this guy has such a great reputation and
also he's just willing to do stuff like
some people you go into their Channel
and they're like I want to do it like
this I don't want to change anything you
know I just want to keep it this way but
when someone's like I just want to blow
up I just want to figure out how to get
more views I'm like that's what I want
to hear let's see what we can do so yeah
yeah so can you reveal some of your
other high profile clients that you work
with so I work with jesser if you've
ever seen his content like viral content
we crush it on shorts it's basically a
basketball Creator he does like a lot of
sports related videos six and a half
million subscribers similar story I went
into his channel and I was like you know
things are good here yeah decent Creator
very good I mean very good Creator he's
doing about 400 500 000 views of video
could we scare this a two could we scale
to three like when I look at a channel
I'm just thinking like what is that
ceiling like could we get it higher and
we essentially started switching to just
higher effort kind of a little bit Mr
beastified Challenge videos with bigger
Stakes so there's a lot more investment
in terms of time and money and also just
thinking more about thumbnails I know
you guys like love think about them yes
and that's one of my favorite things
about you guys because like I can't say
how many creators I come to and it's
just the last thing to think of and
sometimes these are Channels with 10 15
minute subscribers and they're like yeah
I do this on that like the day before
you know I mean we do the thumbnail
usually hours before but it is a
nightmare but you really think about it
yeah gosh it is horrible yeah but it's
fun it's fun when you get it but it's
horrible when you're thinking there it's
like I have no ideas and I hate it and
you got to get something done because we
have a deadline and we have to post
there's been times I've posted late
because I just can't think of the
thumbnail yeah yeah for sure for sure
but again it's a situation it was a
situation like that with jesser where I
just knew he had again like a lot of it
ticked a lot of the sandboxes like he
had a channel that had on top potential
he was creative and good on camera he
had resources and he was willing to
apply feedback like my first call with
them we originally just did one
Consulting call together did that call
instantly they started applying what I
what I told them like there wasn't any
kind of like oh I don't know let me
instantly bang they started applying it
and they started getting results then
they hired me full time and well not
full-time but like a few hours a week in
January and we scaled it up a bit since
then and I work on every video I work on
every thumbnail I still think every
single video could be better and you
know if Jesse or any of the teams listen
to this like we should be getting 10
million if he was a video in my opinion
but yeah we scared our Channel up he's
another Channel I work with a great
Minecraft Channel called Dom Minecraft
not sure if either of you guys are
Minecraft viewers but the mission with
that channel the goal with that channel
is to become the biggest Minecraft
channel in the world
dream pretty much still yeah like and
there's like the dream s p there's Tommy
in it there's a few other guys
um but we're just sort of looking at and
say like this guy is super driven you
can make great videos so we just go into
the channel and like I've been working
with him since January we average about
three and a half four million views of
video in Minecraft so I work with him
who else is there got it Zach alsop ever
seen his content UK YouTuber it sounds
familiar he's he's a another great
Creator cache Jordan he does Real Estate
tours of apartments in New York got
about 300K he's actually my smallest
client sure but a lot of fun with him
and then as well yeah I work with a few
corporations including one massive
Fortune 500 company which I can't reveal
is there any way you could whisper it
and we blink it out just to just to get
our reactions okay
makes sense and it's amazing so you're
doing their social media and stuff so no
they're just their YouTube essentially
like they're wow obviously a massive
company and they have like huge
resources they have huge people working
with them there's so much like I don't
want to reveal who it is but there's so
much built around this company but they
don't have a good YouTube strategy so
last uh April the head of YouTube
reached out to me I worked on one video
with them titled and thumbnails one
video with them did five and a half
million views and their average is like
to 300K if even like quite often it's
less and sometimes there's like paid on
top of that wow so they were like damn
like this this guy knows what he's doing
did a few talks with their teams and now
they're a full-time yeah how does it
work with payment do they pay you way
more than a individual Creator would
like how does that relate to your
overall income it's it's a bigger
package like there's more included so
for example with a lot of the creators I
work with it's just me whereas this
involves like a thumbnail designer that
I bring in it involves my analyst who's
on my team who like devotes a certain
amount of time yeah it's a week so it's
it's a bigger retainer deal with some
like performance stuff involved as well
and what happens hypothetically let's
say you sign on with them and you're
just not getting results or like what
happens if it maybe don't know just it's
not going right what would happen in
that situation I think it depends on
what they're what they're actually
really trying to get out of it because
what I realized about working with
companies like views aren't the only
metric they track they're thinking like
are we moving in the right direction
like are we learning more about this
platform like I think there's it's
different to a YouTuber YouTuber just
looks at pure views but I would say in
general like I'm lucky and I know this
will never be the case because like you
can't be you can't get it right every
single time but every channel I've
worked with over an extended period of
time we've increased views it's just
never happened that we've decreased the
plateau at every single time it's
increased now just the law of odds like
eventually I will come to a channel
where I can't fix so I can't make happen
and you know that might happen the next
year the next two years next three years
I think it just comes down to having a
conversation and like I the way I do
business I literally do not have
contracts like you know NDA stuff sure
but I don't do like hey you're locked in
for two years it's like if we're not
getting results you can just leave yeah
so it's it's like and sometimes clients
have to be patients like I've worked
with clients for like the first month is
a bit slow as we're trying to transition
and trying to make things happen so as
long as it just comes down to like yeah
just be patient and if at any time you
want to leave you want to leave just go
like I'm very friendly with these
clients like I actually chill with them
like we're friends so it's it's not
really like you know
a big deal I've always thought about
that these these massive corporations
have huge budgets and their marketing is
very important they always buy sponsors
just buy sponsorships and stuff like
that but why don't they have an in-house
team that's running their social media
which some companies do but it's never
very effective yeah and if they could
get that it's the perfect targeted
audience the people that like follow or
they just cyber stuff like they don't
throw enough resources at it I mean
we've seen we've seen some where it's
like the whole YouTube team is like two
people and we're like this should be 20.
like Taco Bell's done a good job Taco
Bell's Twitter
but there's quite a few where they don't
take YouTube seriously and they just
hire the bare minimum just to do it but
they're not doing it that well yeah I
see that as well and like it is there's
pros and cons like it's a different
world to working with YouTubers like
there's so much professionalism but it's
also much slower you know like making a
decision takes more time like approving
things takes more time which is natural
but I completely agree like these
companies like why are you spending
hundreds of millions of millions of
dollars on TV TV and you're spending
like a million dollars on YouTube if
even like you have like two people on
your YouTube Team like that's not the
company I'm working with but like just
in general I see that all the time I'm
like why are you not investing more
right like it's where eyeballs are going
can you tell us about your business and
like how many people work with you and
how you've grown that like what's the
back end of that look like yeah I mean
it's it's messy I'd like you to take a
look at it sometime and see what I could
do better and hear your opinion on it
but uh basically like it started as me
obviously because it's the party got
away brand it's my channel I started
working with clients first then over
time I'm like damn I need an assistant
so I hired a PA so I've got a pa okay
then I was like I need help with these
clients especially on stuff that's
repeatable and they can you know have
someone do again and again so I hired a
what I call a YouTube strategist who
just works with me with clients I hired
another YouTube strategist so I have two
YouTube strategists that work with me
the other YouTube strategist is more in
the data side so if there's a client
that wants like a deep dive into their
analytics they want to export everything
build Crazy graphs like that's his bread
and butter
and then I've got a designer that helps
me a little bit with like animations and
stuff for videos and after that I have a
thumbnail designer who's kind of more on
like a kind of retainer contractor basis
but yeah it's like a team of kind of
like four or five depending on how much
you count like six if you count uh
Freelancers too do you have an office
should you just work from home
completely remote this is like it's
crazy like I've been working on YouTube
like with these these YouTubers for a
few years now this is the first time
I've met YouTubers in person apart from
Nate O'Brien yeah in Dublin in 2020. the
first and only like YouTuber you've ever
met in person yeah I mean like before
like I did see I have seen a few since
but like in 2020 when I saw him it was
right before the lockdown like covet
actually wasn't a thing it was like
February you know sure and we just had a
point in a pub in Dublin or a bar as you
guys call them yeah and I just thought
like you know this guy's really smart
he's you know we'd obviously talked a
bit since that video where he commented
on his performance and there's just not
many creators in Ireland you know very
few and then the lockdown happened yeah
so I was supposed to come here Los
Angeles last year and I couldn't get in
because the covert restrictions right so
like this is the first time I've
actually been to America first time
setting foot in America so it's pretty
interesting that's cool so you being the
expert that you are on YouTube
Understanding analytics and statistics
and all of that good back end stuff what
are some content hacks aspiring
YouTubers can do or things that are
commonly overlooked things that people
generally don't do very well that they
can fix to see immediate performance
increase honestly it sounds funny saying
this but like the biggest thing is ideas
like the actual ideas and topics You
cover
it's incredible to me how someone could
like invest maybe tens of thousands of
dollars into a video invest hundreds of
hours into a video but the idea is just
the first thing they thought of you know
just a random oh that'd be a good idea
let's let's just make a video on that
like it just doesn't make sense so
investing a lot of time into ideas how
do you know it's a good idea or a bad
idea yeah I think you have to have like
so what I think about is I think about
like a funnel so I want to come up with
let's say I want to make one video I
want to come up with like a hundred
ideas and then put it through like a
funnel with a filter and that filter
could be like can this video can I think
of a good thumbnail
does this video excite me does this
video have one million view potential
depending on what sort of Channel you
are and like how you decide that is
somewhat subjective but can also be
based on data like maybe we've done this
video before or we've done a similar
before and it's performed really well or
maybe it's performed really well with a
competing Channel or maybe even a
channel in a different Niche to over
perform so we have some at least some
insight into how this could do so that
takes the box and then maybe it's just
like you know how feasible is this to
actually execute like we can all come up
with a crazy idea but maybe it's not
feasible I think of like 100 ideas
filter down to like the 10 with like
criteria like that then when you get to
10 just look at them and say which is
the best like sometimes you do have to
trust your gut I'm someone that loves
data loves analytics but sometimes it's
just like that feels like a better idea
than that one you know let's do that and
let's make that video but I would say
like you know in terms of hacks like
more time on ideas like I worked with Mr
Beast for a few months last year and
like that was eye-opening to me how like
ideas are everything especially for
entertainment channels I think it's a
bit different than other niches but like
even Graham yourself I'm sure you know
like if you get a good topic it's going
yeah yeah what else beyond that I would
say like intros is one of the biggest
problems that creators have
understanding how to hook someone how to
get to the point and how not how to not
put too much context in I think way too
many creditors put way too much context
in their intros I don't want to hear all
this explanation I just want to hear
delivery I just want to hear us flow
into the rest of the story that's
another thing as well like it might
sound obvious to you guys but so many
creators have like an intro reel you
know like a little like oh I hate that
there was just there was one I watched
where the intro reel was 50 seconds
are you gonna do it Jack no I'm talking
about one of this pre-recorded words in
front of every single video where it's
like that like 50 seconds 50 seconds
right like so I've studied like
thousands of retention curves across
I want to say hundreds that's maybe a
bit of an exaggeration but like dozens
of niches I've never seen an entry of
serve a purpose like if they're just not
you they're not useful they don't
they're not needed I honestly like with
my videos like my videos take me but
maybe like
somebody doesn't mind take like 100
hours to finalize with between scripting
and like editing and everything together
and let's just say it's a 10 minute
video you would think like each minute
has a 10 time allocation the reality is
I spend like 30 to 40 of the time on the
first minute just to make sure every
word is right and I have that Liberty
because I post infrequently I think it's
harder when you're posting a lot of
content to be able to go into that
detail but that's how strong I feel
about how you start the video so like
talk about hacks like faster intros that
get to the point and don't like I always
say an intro that doesn't feel like an
intro like if I can point at your intro
and just see so clearly where it ends
and it's like okay now let's get into
the video
why didn't you just start there you know
that's like that's like the biggest
interact so that's that's definitely
another thing that people need to work
on I'd love for you to critique our
content I think that'd be great yeah I
think one thing I I was actually mean
like if ever If Ever I came into this
podcast yeah I was gonna ask you what
the the smash the like obviously it's so
funny because I was about to ask you
have you found if likes affect the
performance of the video so likes likes
and video performance are slightly
correlated so there is like a
relationship between a video that gets
more likes gets more views of course
it's not as important as retention so
the question for me and the question for
you yeah is really if by having the like
CTA if you like let's see let's say that
like CTA leads to like a three percent
drop or four percent drop in retention
the way I would think about this is it's
trade-offs like now you have three or
four percent people who've left the
video and what you've got is more likes
but if retention is weighted higher than
likes I would always prioritize the
retention so my like button smashing is
usually about 10 to 15 seconds the
maximum and I always include a picture
of a baby thank you yeah and I feel like
people like that because some people
request now in the comments I want a
picture of a baby dolphin or like I want
you know a hedgehog in the next one so
I'll see the comments I'll be like all
right I'll I'll take a note and then
I'll put up a picture of a hedgehog or
you know whatever that is okay so you
also get comments that are like stop
begging for likes and stuff they've been
saying that since the very beginning
there's always going to be somebody
who's too complaining take out your
anecdote experience about people
praising you for the for them no because
because no because you you I see out of
a hundred comments one person's like
you're begging for likes and then the
other 99 people don't care and they hit
the like button and they like it there's
gonna be a person who complains over
everything people complain about my
voice how I look how I move my arms
which I think help retention because it
makes a video more appealing that people
can find everything to complain about
there's gonna be everything you know
yeah I mean obviously comments like you
can get some decent data from like you
know how people are feeling about a
video yeah but really it's about the
retention curve like when you do like I
don't I don't really care too much about
people say positive or negative I care
about those moments where you introduce
that like CTA are you losing a
significant amount of retention what's
your advice for people who might want to
be in a position like you to consult and
make money on the back end from YouTube
honestly don't don't see it as like a
making money opportunity to begin with
like I actually do it as like a YouTuber
like become try to become a YouTuber
yourself like I make a living for my
channel I don't necessarily need to do
this like if I wanted to just like get
by I could just live on my channel so
like I'm a YouTuber first and then a
YouTube consultant second like that's
the sort of the way it's gone for me so
I'd say if anyone wants to do this I
would say either start your own channel
and just obsess over that and try to
make it the biggest challenge you can or
go and find like an upcoming YouTuber or
like you know let's just say Matthew
beam like last year as Matthew beam was
growing like if you want to become a
consultant like why not message Matthew
and say hi I want to work with you and
just learn with every video apply this
stuff build a case study and then over
time you might be able to take on more
clients what everyone wants to do is
like everyone's skip the step when
you're like an employee and you're
working and you're grinding and you're
spending like 60 hours a week getting
nothing they want to skip straight to
the expert bit where you're like getting
the high rates and the the speaker fees
and stuff so I think it takes time like
you know and I think it depends on what
you
what you're working with as well sure
like what sort of skills you actually
have as a person I'm curious though what
are your thoughts on the Mr
beastification of YouTube I'm noticing
that I click random channels now what's
up you guys today we're gonna tell the
five things and it's like the same
format now over and over and over again
it's interesting to see and now I feel
like it's almost becoming less effective
because so many people are doing that I
mean it's difficult because oh we should
get this Alex has had his wisdom teeth
removed okay I'm gonna record this
yeah I'm
he did
how are you doing Alex
is did you get them out yet or no
they did
yeah
oh my gosh did it hurt
we'll do it
I want to make sure I don't I don't know
if we want to see it Alex we're gonna
get demonetized no whoa whoa Alex turn
it back now I don't want to see it how
are you okay Alex
what do you want to say to the viewers
who are you interviewing uh Patty
Galloway what's up man
hey
[Music]
Patty you have any questions for Alex on
his teeth removal I I have wisdom teeth
pain is it worth it man is the is this
worth it Alex
what getting your teeth removed oh no
no hey Alex what's what do you think
working for me is it okay am I a good
boss you can't do this to him well he's
under the influence of something no this
is not fair
no I love you so much
it's good Jack is okay
oh he knows what he's doing he knows
what he's doing yeah it's here okay Jack
never gave me a phone
and I don't believe in bonuses he does
he said he doesn't believe in bonuses I
give bonuses to people that bring me SD
cards
you see he knows he's he's owed me SD
cards for a long time
sorry my friend called me oh thank you
all right Alex we'll let you go okay
tell people to subscribe oh also
um because I'm working right now yes
Alexa
um Workshop is the official card sponsor
because they're awesome so it's so
awesome
thank you so much
believe it all right Alex good luck I'll
see you I love you okay love you too
that's podcast gold so Humphrey's uh
behind the camera here he had a really
good question
um what is your advice between smaller
creators and bigger creators because
sometimes as a bigger Creator what I'm
doing isn't necessarily going to help
somebody else grow if they're just
starting out honestly it's cliche you
know you hear everyone say it but like
you need volume like you need to make a
high quantity of videos before you get
to a place where you can actually even
contemplate making a high quality video
it's like I always say like people come
up to me all the time they're like hey
you know I've made four videos I've got
no results check them out like I've been
optimizing thumbnails I've been
switching thumbnails and like if you're
switching thumbnails and you're getting
like 100 Impressions on a video it's not
gonna be doing anything you know so I
always say it's people like that just
make more content like what are you
doing make 100 150 200 videos I made
probably a thousand videos across
different channels before I was even
monetized you know and that's that's
more more than most people and now on my
current Channel I've got 30 videos and
I've got 400k that wouldn't have
happened if I didn't post a thousand
videos so I think with small credit it's
just about making a lot of content and
then as well you do have to be more kind
of like shoulders out trying to like you
know jump on Trends Trend jacking like
trying to find anything to attach your
brand to like a big event a big name
another YouTuber that's kind of the way
you do it whereas a big YouTuber you
have something to lose so you have to
consider your audience you have to
consider you know do I go with the
quantity or quality approach like I talk
quite a lot about some of my clients we
we lower quantity but we just increase
quality whereas other people like when
they lower quantity they just don't have
that extra level to go up or maybe the
ceiling is not that much higher so that
it just doesn't make any sense yeah but
that's the biggest thing I think small
creators just don't think about anything
except making videos just make more yeah
that's what I kind of tell people too is
that um the first I always say like the
first like 50 videos are gonna suck so
it's better just get those out of the
way and just post 50 videos like I'd
rather see someone consistent about
posting bad videos and posting nothing
or overthinking it because they're gonna
suck anyway so it's better just to get
that out of the way and there's a steep
learning curve for the first maybe 20 or
so this is better just to start make all
the mistakes you'll get better and then
like video 21 then you start thinking
through these things exactly exactly
like you don't you don't learn that
without doing it you know and it's
it's just one of those things people
just want things too quickly I I sound
like a boomer but you know these YouTube
kids these days they want a million
subscribers with 10 videos what do you
think what do you think of shorts and
Tick Tock I love shorts like Tick Tock I
don't I don't really live in like I just
live in the YouTube world like I feel
like YouTube is going to eat Tick Tock
yeah I think YouTube's gonna eat twitch
like I am just like 100 YouTube that's
just my game so I think about YouTube
shorts I think how they relate to long
form and like I'll just say with most of
my long-term clients we do shorts on the
main Channel and they do great shorts
and long form can coexist perfectly fine
the only thing I hate is how YouTube
rolled it out so it's all like mixed in
together like I feel like they should
have waited to separate it first yeah
but I love shorts like we have a short
on Jess's channel that has like 38
million views and you know that's just
one like we have like multiple shorts
with 10 20 million views yeah Instagram
bugs me with that so much when you go to
someone's Instagram page and you see
like all the videos mixed in with the
pictures it should be like pictures
video like tags that's it and YouTube I
feel like should have that too because I
don't like going to someone's videos
page and it's like riddled with shorts
and I'm like scrolling through to find
the one video they just had videos
shorts like the same thing would be
would be so much better did we finish uh
the Mr beastification of YouTube no we
never we don't know we never I just
realized that what are your thoughts on
that because I saw that video uh that
one guy did and it was so good oh yeah
the really long one it's like a 50
minute long expose about like you know
these I don't say Mr B's copycats but
there's definitely a style and a format
that people have taken to that just it's
the Mr beastification it's like the meta
for like you know entertainment channels
so like I mean the first thing I would
say is like the guy making that video it
was a really good video by the way I
thought I thought it was great video but
if you look at that guy like how old is
he I know like early 20s yeah he is not
the demographic for who the channels
he's criticizing are making content for
and if you actually look at the data on
a lot of these channels like people say
oh it's getting stale but like when they
do something that maybe has more
relationship building or maybe a vlog or
slower Pace they get a million View use
when they do like a challenge and
they're like hey guys it's me and we're
doing this two minute views you know
it's kind of hard when you have that
instant feedback group to say this is
working but I do agree like you know
there's too many people that just see
what Jimmy does and just goes like you
know obviously he's the ghost we're just
gonna copy this verbatim and just go
like that I think I think too many
people copy it I think as well like if
we're in a space where everyone is
copying Jimmy we're never gonna get
another Jimmy you know we're not gonna
get the next Jimmy and I remember a
conversation I had with Iraq a while ago
it was the best conversation had about
this he booked in with a consultant
called me last year and he goes you know
I'm not that interested with what Mr
Beast is doing because I know the next
Mr Beast won't be making content like Mr
Beast like I love that because it's so
true yeah you know he like Jimmy has
just nailed it he does everything right
no one can compete with him at that
scale at that level and it's not just
money it's like the Intel the team you
you visit his HQ unbelievable you know
like they've just got the smartest
people in the world working there
smartest YouTube people in the world
working there so I think you're always
going to be smarter than the person
you're copying and in that regard and I
don't know like I do think a lot of
people like you know our age and you
know we look at it and say ah this is
like corny too much but like is it for
me that's the question I was asked like
is this content actually but can't you
look at that and see like okay maybe
overall the interest is not as high as
it was two years ago you there's it's
it's on a decline now it's like we're
getting 10 few reviews and six months
ago on average people like that that are
watching it or growing up and the people
coming into that age or maybe not as
interested because they're going for
something else instead because I'm
seeing a lot of younger people now
gravitating more towards uh I think the
shorts uh yeah talk just quick content
than they are
10 to 20 minute long videos that are you
know quick Fast Pace yeah because that's
from what I've observed as a 30
something year old yeah I think you
don't look 30. yeah I think I would have
said like 20 28. oh great
um now but I I would say like yes to an
extent there's a few things we have to
consider because everything with me has
to be boring data so first thing to
consider is during the pandemic
viewership was all-time highs yes so
it's kind of like when people say like
views might be down compared to two
years ago it's like that's another
Factor we have to put into the equation
and that's like an important thing to
consider but then after that I just
think like
realistically
what works on YouTube shifts over time
we're seeing a lot of people starting to
consume shorts I don't think shorts and
long form compete necessarily but
naturally it's like eyeballs gonna go on
you know like you only have a certain
amount of time in a day like if Shorts
start taking more of that time that
takes away from long form I do think
what Ryan Tran did was just phenomenal
like I I love that guy like I think I
think what he did was amazing because he
still had like the the lessons from the
Mr Beast spectacle generation but he
added more story and I think I think
this I just really believe this
our generation of people between the
ages of like I don't like 23 and like
maybe like 35 like this this generation
we have very few like big entertainment
channels that we point to and say like
that's our YouTuber like four or five
years ago with Casey and like everyone
watched Casey you know and he was making
content for like guys and girls in the
20s and 30s who is there now like it
feels like a lot of YouTubers have just
like scaled or like focused their effort
on the younger audience because it's
bigger like the younger audience is
massive with YouTube and also things
like merch and things that can be crazy
and as you grow older you become into
more like niches like finance and like
other areas I mean that's why but like
we're missing a Casey neistat and I
think Ryan Trey might be kind of filling
that role I'm interested to see how it
develops yeah who are some creators that
you would invest in let's say you could
invest in three creators at their
current status and you can invest in Mr
Beast who are three creators you'd
invest Mr based okay hands down like
still even oh yes current value oh yeah
yeah like Mysteries being my first first
I think Mysteries is more likely to 10x
than like a lot of other YouTubers okay
like the scale of everything about these
videos we're talking about him as a
brand I'm thinking about like the whole
package like if I'm investing in someone
like I don't watch the videos get to a
certain point kind of like what
Facebook's dealing with right now where
they're trying to expand their their you
know Their audience or whatever but they
can't because the population isn't
getting faster yeah
kids yeah so for Mr Beast too I'm sure
there's going to be a point where like I
mean he can't apply his main Channel
English content to more than you know oh
yes the English speaking India
that's that's the thing that's like what
there's like there's like 1.2 billion
English speaking
uh people in the whole world it's like
as a first something like that and
there's like 1.5 billion people in India
you know I'm gonna look stupid if my
geography's wrong but I think it's like
over a billion people just in India wow
so like
also cultural differences not just
English there are plenty of things yeah
like but I I don't know I think I think
it's it's like
Mr Beast is at the level where he can
make such a big spectacle that like like
I know what the idea is like if he's
making these ideas now in five years
true what is he gonna do I think the
only thing is like if maybe he decides
he wants to do something different which
you know you you guys have met him yeah
you know it doesn't seem like he's ever
gonna be like that and like just the
thing about thing about YouTubers is
like everyone talks about this YouTube
life cycle but like you have a few years
at the top then you drop off and win in
popularity and I think that's true for a
lot of cases but if you look at those
cases did they innovate did they try
something new or did they just stay with
the gravy train and you know keep going
and not really adapt to the current
times or changes that can quite often be
what happens with the you know the life
cycle of declining over time so Mr Beast
first and foremost I invested him like
100 like I just the plans they have what
he's trying to do like that guy is
another level right
um and I genuinely think that I would I
would not have said this like a year ago
or two years ago Iraq again he's a big
Creator so you're thinking like there's
not that much upside but when I I
remember talking to him after he just
hit a million subscribers and I thought
his content was really weak after he hit
a million subscribers like he did this
like super bowl video where he was
sneaking into the Super Bowl but he
didn't actually sneak in but he posted
it I was like that's just such a it was
such a weak video for me like I just
like that felt so disappointing and I
remember it underperformed a little bit
at the time as well he had a few other
videos around there I remember them very
specifically getting like 400k 500k like
a million views which is great but like
for where he was aiming it wasn't it and
I thought I just didn't think he and his
team maybe had the potential but since
then I think they've been killing it
like his videos are so easy to watch
they're filling this gap of like like Mr
B's like the wholesome like everybody
kind of like loves some kind of
character and Eric's is kind of like kid
in detention like he's just doing crazy
stuff you know I think he feels it fails
a different niche in YouTube and I think
they're doing some really interesting
things so I'd say I'd say Eric
and then I'd have to pick someone more
on the come up I know a guy that you
won't know but he's a really good
Creator so there's a guy called Santiago
and his channel is called foot Crunch
and he makes FIFA videos like FIFA the
game like the soccer game he's got to a
point where he's kind of like a million
views of video but I'd invest in him
because I I know because I've done a bit
of work with him and I know what his
plans are what he's trying to do so
if I had like 100 Grand to invest in him
I would because he's trying to go after
a really broad big audience and he's
just super obsessed like he's not trying
to like get to like five million dollar
net worth or like five million
subscribers he's trying to like build
something massive so he's wanting to
watch out for everything that's cool uh
one thing I want to mention though about
Mr Beast is she talked on Andrew
Schultz's podcast about maybe running
for president I think he has a real shot
I honestly believe he would win if he if
he runs at you know 40 something years
old probably in his 40s with with no
prior experience I bet he could win yeah
I agree yeah by then because kids would
have grown up yes everyone would have
grown up with him and would trust him
and he gives away so much money
and I think everyone the US population
will have received money from us in some
way or another yeah but I think that
that's gonna be a thing and I think I I
really just think it comes down to does
he want to do that yeah and I think he's
got a real shot at it it'll be very hard
for someone to say I hey Mr Beast like
have you ever heard someone say I mean
probably there's terrible people out
there but like you know it's kind of
hard to make an argument against
something the thing would be though I
guess with him alienating some of his
audience by picking aside because he's
gonna have to pick Republican or
Democrat yeah most likely and you know
what effect does that have they're gonna
try to tear them down anyway but I think
if he wants to do it he's okay putting
himself on the spotlight I think he
could do it is there like an age
requirement 35 35 okay yeah I mean I've
talked to Jimmy quite a few times I've
been in some very long Discord calls
them as well like anything that guy says
he wants to do like I just believe yeah
you know I just he's just it's like you
know that we read a book about like
Steve Jobs or you know these kind of
visionary people one of the most
effective things they're they're good at
not just like the design or the coding
it's like making people buy into what
they're trying to do everything that guy
says I'm like he's gonna do that if he
if he tells me tomorrow he's gonna like
make pigs fly I'm like they're flying
it's already done you know yeah that's
the kind of guy he told Jack and I have
some video ideas where
I I loved the idea so much and they were
so genius and I'm thinking first of all
how come nobody else ever thought of
this and why didn't I think of this
because it's so obvious and so good
yeah no we did a comment myself and him
there I don't know it's maybe like
February and he basically just told me
like the videos he was planning to make
for the whole year and he just asking
for my opinion on them yeah and I was
like yeah that sounds good this sounds
like it was like one or two I was like
I'm not sure about but like there was 10
ideas there that I was like
I could get 100 million views yeah you
know and that's like the standardy
setting it's just crazy yeah I would
love for him to run for president at the
age of 35 and just be president then and
like just beat every record what's who's
the youngest president I think like late
30s right no one's ever done it at 35.
yeah no one's ever done it at 35 though
just be 35 years yeah he could do it I I
think he could but it would it would
mean he'd have to put his channel on the
side or would it yeah just imagine if he
runs against Elon Musk I think he would
just back out just just out of respect
for Elon yeah be like Elon no you take
this this this term is you and then I'll
do the next one yeah yeah just imagine
that imagine the titles he could come up
with if he was present
oh God his speeches would be so
optimized too yeah yeah he just like
ended really quickly
okay
yeah and then I've got 100 people over
there yeah yeah
um and uh I want you I think it would be
really interesting for you to rank every
piece of data that YouTube gives you
from most important to least you know
like CTR uh average duration uh stuff
like that watch time
if you could just maybe rank like your
top three to five or something like that
well the best is views like views is
like the god tier metric and it sounds
funny to say that but like I don't care
about the CTR and avd until I know what
the views are because of the relativity
between like views and and a CTR and avd
yeah so like view views number one like
that's number one metric then like CTR
and avd it's like hard to put one in
front of the other like I think I think
I put them on a level beside uh or just
underneath views like there is there is
no way to say which is more important
like you need both like it's pretty it's
pretty even formula like if you have a
video that everyone clicks on but people
click off YouTube are going to bury that
video so like I think that's pretty even
and then after that I think you just you
just have things like you know the
initial like the notification
click-through rate or something yeah
first 30 second retention or likes
shares dislikes comments comments
actually here's a fun fact your comments
have like no weight in the algorithm at
all really the number of comments don't
don't have any impacts purity because
look at this right so yeah let's just
say comments made a big deal so like
number of comments is a big deal I could
reply to every comment with a question
and double my comments you know true and
now that's just that's just engagement
farming but but also like it's just easy
to like create spam accounts for
comments is it a bit harder for like
views and so like part of the reason I
believe because in the beginning that
was not the case and I don't see a huge
difference because I would respond to
comments for the first hour of every
single video across all three channels
yeah and I would notice an immediate
difference when I was not responding to
the comments every single time without
fail the video would not perform as well
then if I was responding I think because
of the spam comments they've maybe
turned off that feature and looking at
other metrics because sometimes now I'll
get a thousand spam comments in a row
yeah uh and have to go through and
delete them and so maybe they're taking
those out of the equation and also it's
like a comment like essentially when you
think about the algorithm like the
algorithm is trying to predict audience
Behavior so everything they're trying to
do is understand the audience and like
sure leaving a comment on the video is
like a good indication you like the
video I guess if it's a positive comment
but like YouTube aren't going to go
through the filtering and see like it
was this a positive sentiment because
like you know it's hard to judge not
just you know from the outside so like
it's just it's just too complicated and
also like those things that you can kind
of gamify it I think I think it's good
from like a engagement perspective to
ask for comments not for the algorithm
but for like your your community to like
feel involved in the content and then
like I remember I read it or maybe I was
watching it too with you talking about
that we were like I like reply to every
comment in the first hour and I just
love that because like a lot of people
don't do that like I'll be honest like
my last video I posted that video I
think maybe provides like two comments
you know that's that's silly I think it
helps with your community because then
people will click on that notification
knowing that they can watch and then
comment and they'd they'd get a response
but if they're already on the video
maybe they're more likely to finish it
yeah
um yeah I responded to every single
comment on my channel until I hit a
million subscribers every single one of
them that's insane yeah I stopped at a
million but it became a compulsion where
I'd wake up I could not get out of bed
until I responded to every comment and
eventually I'd start waking up early and
earlier because it would take me longer
and longer and longer and then I
wouldn't go to bed until every comment
was answered
um up until that point where I had to
fall asleep that's awesome
yeah because like people just honestly
like it's so it's so interesting like
I've obviously got to work with some of
the biggest creators in the world got to
like be in the same room with these
people the same causes these people and
lots of them are really really like
obsessed with the audience which is good
but I have met people who are kind of
they do see it more as kind of like this
sort of like
you know almost like a chore like we
have to like oh to like reply to a
comment or you know to do this and that
the creators I love the most people that
do like think of that you know like
you're thinking like if I were
practicing this company shows them that
I really care and it's good for you but
it's also good for them as well to be
like damn like this actually means
something to him you know my favorite
thing is uh commenting on random
channels like not random yeah like but
like small channels that maybe I watch a
video and I'll just put like great video
yeah but like the most random stuff and
it's just cool to see like see their
responses yeah I even get that even
though my channel is quite a bit smarter
because like a lot of YouTubers when
they're starting they might come across
my videos so like they start their
Channel and I just reply to like I put a
comment on it saying like this is a
great video like this could blow up and
they're like oh my God like I just
watched your video before it's such a
good feeling yeah no there's one I
commented this guy was doing like a
Philip Glass cover on the piano and the
video maybe have like 100 views
commented like dude this this cover is
awesome yeah this is I really like to
see this big verified Channel yeah yeah
like 100 views they probably just
uploaded it as like a piano recital or
something like that like not expecting
anything but it's so encouraging because
I remember having like less subscribers
and just seeing like someone leave a
comment it's like like you know you see
the verified badge you see maybe if you
know the name it's just such like a a
nice kind of
thing to keep you going yeah yeah there
any questions you have for us or any
advice things that you see us do that is
completely wrong and backwards I think
I'm interested with the the like scaling
because I've heard a lot a lot of
conversations where you've gone back and
forth on the kind of wiring process I
would say like on average I would slide
with Jack in the area but that's
probably gonna make you a loot it's not
an absolute though because you're
backing out I I can see your perspective
though like because you've you've built
like this incredible Channel yeah it's
doing really well I would assume from
your point of view you probably look at
him you can correct me from wrong you
probably think there's not that much
extra juice to get out of the finance
niche in terms of views per video so
like is it worth it to scale and expand
but I think about it from like the
personal point of view of like are you
not working all the time like I know
that might be what you love Yeah like
are you gonna kind of maybe I don't know
hit yeah 40 and say like damn I just
worked for 15 20 years but I like it
yeah like today there really wasn't as
much for me to do and I was I don't want
to say it was miserable but like
it's not a good day yeah it's had an off
day because they didn't have as much to
do as I wanted to that's because you
don't have any like other like Hobbies
or things that you can pick up to past
time in the meantime it's gang up on
Graham's time
all of your free time with work then
when all of a sudden work isn't there
it's like you can't be content no I went
I went on a run today three months three
miles that make you feel good uh it did
I actually what I do is I download
videos to listen to on the Run that's
good when was awesome you went on
vacation uh
I don't know we've we well we do little
trips Jack and I have done a few like
weekend trips
I took a two-week vacation
um I'm trying to I find it difficult to
do it because obviously you know I work
a lot as well I obviously have to keep
things going but I tried to take like a
vacation once a quarter yeah because I
just think of it like it recharges me it
makes me better it makes me think about
it doesn't for me for me no when I get
off that treadmill it's so hard to get
back on like when I'm on the treadmill
what does it for me is speed it up a
little bit let's let's ramp it up yeah
when you said that you don't like when
you have a day when you don't do stuff
and you feel terrible yeah I relate to
that because I because like when I I
just remember like I I discovered this
incredible concept called the weekend
you know like not the not the artist the
actual weekend and I was like wow like
people take Saturdays and Sundays off
this is like insane like let me try this
my first few times doing it I felt awful
like I was just like I want to do
something I want to work I want to think
of video ideas I want to like maybe I
could take on a new clients and just
work with them on the weekends you know
I was just thinking how can I feel that
time and then like it's same with
vacations like let's say you take a week
off first three days of that vacation
you know my girlfriend doesn't even want
to talk to me it's like I'm just like I
just want to do it I just want to work
and like No don't touch your laptop and
after like three or four days I feel
like finally like I'm kind of unplugging
like by day five day six day seven like
I actually just spend a full day
actually just enjoying like I mean going
to the beach first few days are the
easiest for me and then after day three
or four and now I'm like anxious to get
so you're the you're the complete
opposite the opposite yeah I mean
everyone's everyone's different but yeah
that's how I think because I'm always at
this constant balance of like I got for
example it's similar with you guys I'm
with you too like you know like by let's
say if we each worked another 10 hours a
week like that equates to a lot of money
but then like how much further does that
push you towards burnout how much
further does that push you towards
having no free time so I I see I think
sometimes like we'd offered like a lot
of money like let's just say it's like
15 20 000 a month to do like something
in a few hours per week or 10 hours per
week or something I might look at that
and go like that's a that's a big
opportunity it's a lot of money and I
have this like hard balance of like do I
take too much on do I take [ __ ] and I
think I definitely like skew to the side
of like taking too much on like I feel
like like there are weeks when I worked
like 70 80 hours maybe I mean 90 is
probably too much like 78 hours no
problem but the the happiest I am is
when I have like at least a bit of time
in the evenings like it feels good to be
able to shut your laptop at like 7 PM oh
I do but yeah yeah for me it's like a
productive day and then end at like
seven
really yeah yeah and you've always been
like that just work every day always
wow I mean I gotta gotta respect it yeah
I keep getting my mind like changed on
this sort of stuff though because like I
remember when I was like 22 23 it was
like grind grind garyvee also hustle
hustle crazy and then like I got really
into like different philosophy read a
few books listened to a few people and
then I was like oh like it's life isn't
about work it's all about chilling out
and enjoyment and stuff like that and I
spent like a little bit of time trying
to do this whole work-life balance thing
and now I figured out that I don't have
balance like I'm not a work-life balance
person but like I want to be the person
who like works hard but then takes
breaks hard you know and has that like
balance of like I might for like 10
weeks in a quarter I might work like
crazy and then two weeks I'm just like
flat I want a Lilo in the south of Spain
that's kind of how I see things for me
all right
so yeah cool Graham doesn't like this
conversation
if we if we had an extra hour I would go
off on it for an hour yeah 7 30. and so
that's why I'm just like just in case I
have to go on a boat yeah hopefully this
boat doesn't leave because then we
wouldn't be able to go and we never
found out if it's leaving or not I know
we got we got nothing back so let's just
hope fingers crossed I just want to say
hello come on get it yeah get in here
all right look we got some guests over
here what's up guess hey hey what's up
which camera am I looking at there's so
many of them oh they're all good they're
all points
NATO Jack's on the couch right I I have
the king bed I am on the couch we can
share the king bed tonight if you want
we'll see we'll see can I hop in there
yeah yeah
I like a warm bed thanks for joining us
here on the iced coffee hour do you have
any questions what did you guys think
did it go well I thought it went great
were you here the whole time no I came
in like two minutes ago okay but Patty's
a great guy yeah I thought you guys
covered a really wide range of topics
and I think the viewer will take away a
lot from it so I hope they subscribe
awesome that's a good point it's awesome
thank you guys yeah get your free stock
subscribe check me
thanks for watching guys till next time
awesome